χρόνο ρεκόρδιόμηση χρόνια τααπότε δικηγόρς και ότα παχρει της στημού ου φτασεν το προφωρικό μάθημα
δεν έίχαν τη δύναμη να αντικρίσω το δάσκαλον και ένα μιλήσω αυτό πουγάνω τώρα ταμαθημα
από επέρασε στο ράνομιζααμνωε κάνε και έτσι παράτησα το πανετιστήμεον έφυγα έκαμα μια ενεδεργά στην
κύπρο μπήκαμε στο βάνο ίδιος γύριζαν κύπρο πουλούς αχύρι εανεμιστήρες κουβάες εύκαλα ζίνες πουλαρούμε εδούλεψα
κληρά έκαμα το πρώτομε έκα το μήρο ναφαίνεται αστείον αλλά καμενανα κατοπύριον λύρεσαν το πιστεύετι
ό που τούτα τα πράγματα μέσα σε διο χρόνια ε χριπο αναγάλιψα έναν πάθοσμου που
ήταν το κουμάρι το οποίον εξηγώ μέσα στο βιβλίο μου πως ακριβώς έχει γεννηθεί και
τουλάχιστον σεμένα αυτόν το βάθος ξεκίνησαν τα ζάρκα τους τα άλογα και ότι έκτήσα σε
δο χρόνια κάματα και ημά έμεινε ατάσι των ζόγον ο χριστόφορος έφτασε στα όρια του
τα ξεπέρασε τα ωριά του έχα σε λεφτά αναγκάστηε να φύγει από την κύπρο λόγο
τηςτόυτων το πράγμα να ξεξήγουράφυγα από την κύπρον καταχρεωμένως ότι ξα το αυτοκ ίναι τον
που το διαμέρισμα που είχαν ποείνι ν μέκαδικό μου ταξέ ήταν τα και οφαενάς πήρα
και τανικά από τοκογλήφους έν ίχαα τους πληρώσω πιασαένα νατοπλάνω και έφύγαμε προρισμό τη ρουμανία
με το βρακή που φορούσα γνώρισα το στέγειο των τρήφωναν οποίοσοπατέρας του ς ενέργοστάσιω αι
χρησιοκάντα στη λογική μου δημούργησανα νέργοστάσειον από τομιδε τώρα να μου πείτετα ποαμαγάμα πράγματα που
πορακαταλάβειο ανθρωπινοςμούς βρήκαμαν κυβερνητι γίνεταιρία τους είπτα καμ έκαμανα μιέκαμα μια μελέ της σεραχαρτή τους
είπανε χρέθέουμε να ξακός εχιλιάς δολάνα γαμε ένα εργοστάσειν τα μηχανήμετα στεγίζουνται τρακόσες εδώ κα
μου ότο το τριαντατρέά τις έγατόν τοτατραόσω ιιάδων περίβο το γαγατόν πεταχειάς περίπο αγράσαμε εανήμα
τα μόνομεψαράντα χεγιάες μείνα μου και κατόν είχαι το ξεξητή σε κατώς συνέτερος με το
σταγειών των τρήφωνα και ξεκινήσαμε να γάνουμεγάλατα κτα λιπά νε στα θα ξεχάσω που μμεροστέκαι
ως ότι